it's an impressive show of firepower
from a country that is cementing its
position as a leading arms manufacturer
in a mountainous valley turned into a
battlefield south korea's defense
industry puts on display its latest
weaponry in particular heavy armor for a
gathering of international buyers and
media
countries with the ability to buy
weapons place great importance on seeing
them used in the field they want to see
them in action south korea's defence
exports this year have already reached
an all-time high with much of that
growth driven by the war in ukraine
poland in particular has signed a record
deal to replace equipment that it has
supplied to the ukrainians
equipment manufactured to nato
specifications makes it attractive to
european nations wanting to bolster
their defenses
the landline when it
nato member countries have a system of
collective security but there's an
increasing feeling each country should
be able to defend itself and korean
weapons are cost effective and
internationally proven
similarly according to u.s intelligence
russia is looking to north korea to
replenish its stocks of soviet-era
shells and rockets
it seems decades-old tensions on the
peninsula have now involved both careers
in a far away war
it's partly because of the threat from
north korea that south korea has been
pushing the development of its own
defense industries it means with its
industrial might it's ideally placed to
meet the growing global demand for new
sophisticated weaponry and as the number
of visitors from developing asian
countries seems to indicate growing
regional tensions are also driving
demand closer to home
not only russia's war in ukraine but as
you well know there is a situation
related to taiwan so countries feel the
urgent need for security in a world of
growing confrontations korean arms
makers it seems will have no shortage of
orders
rob mcbride al jazeera goyang south
korea